so recently this bitcoin thing um
craig wright i don't know much about it
other than like one article i read i
guess he's an australian guy and he was
being sued by this person who wanted a
share of the money for
what's the story uh i don't know about
his lawsuit but i know about craig
wright and that he basically for a long
time has been claiming to be
uh satoshi nakamoto so well so he claims
to be the creator of bitcoin and then
people who are smart in the community
are like there's no way so
people but the this lawsuit basically
he's being sued by the spouse of someone
this ma this craig wright had a partner
the partner died and the spouse of the
partner sued craig wright and craig
wright won the lawsuit and winning for
what uh she said that you owe me money
because of this reason and that reason
we created this you and my husband
created this thing together you owe us
some money and in winning i forget
exactly how it worked but in winning the
case the
jurors said well no you're satoshi and
you worked on this alone
and so uh
like in order for him to win
in a weird i don't know the exact
details but in order for him to win they
were basically saying yes we believe
you're satoshi and satoshi worked alone
so okay here's here's the story so
uh kleinman versus wright
the jury ruled that david kleinman's
relationship to craig wright did not
constitute a business partnership
meaning the estate was not entitled to a
share of the satoshi nakamoto fortune
which wright claims to have control over
as the self-purported creator of bitcoin
the
jury ruled against wright on the
conversion count awarding
awarding 100 million dollars to kleinman
what a rule against right yeah so he
said they got 100 million out of it i
don't know because i thought he was
celebrating it was a little confusing
but the point was is that this like
this legal team okay they wanted
billions they didn't get that but they
got 100 million against him for the
unauthorized use of funds from climate
and wright's shared venture wnk info
defense research llc oh god this is from
something else so did this guy the guy
who started it that's what i wanted so
so basically um so he claims to have
invented bitcoin
then um there's a great clip by the way
of vitalik buterin the creator of
ethereum uh co-creator of ethereum
uh on stage and he goes uh there's they
were talking about it and usually people
like you know like in a w in a
conference panel people are usually
pretty like
you know they don't take shots at people
like live there and he just he just
pipes because you want to know what i
think
and they're like yes we'd love to know
what you think he goes
he goes um
he gives this like quick like two-minute
rant that just destroys craig right
where he's like i think if you're the
creator of bitcoin you have a v and
everybody was saying you're not and you
keep trying to tell people you are all
you have to do is one simple thing you
just have to sign something with
satoshi's wallet and that will just show
that you're him and the fact that you're
not doing that like the you know he he
calls some like some like you know
awesome razer oxen's razor or whatever
like just some term like that he's like
the simplest explanation here is that
you're not satoshi because if you have a
simple way to prove your claim and you
do not prove your claim using the simple
way
you cannot prove your claim
and um so you kind of just like on
him right there so who crowd went wild
so who is this you think is he he just
died or he's still quiet
um
the best theory is that it's uh
that it's this guy hal i forgot his name
is hal uh hal finney um
this was so hal finney was like a
cryptographer he received the first
bitcoin transaction he was the like the
second wallet and normally like
what does a developer do when they test
something that's like oh i send it from
like sean a to sean b like my test
account basically like that's how i do
the first transaction
and um he was like very active in the
forums and then he died right around the
time he got als and died around the time
that the last known time that stoshi
ever posted anything um
so you know what he was like why
wouldn't he tell
do you think he
why wouldn't he like tell his wife or
his family or you know like
because it looks like he has a wife on
these pictures yeah
well a maybe he did and b um like you
know some people are
so mission driven in their thing and
they're thinking and like you know there
was a there's a real genius of
the idea of being like i'm gonna have
this as a pseudonymous name satoshi
nakamoto i'm not gonna use my real name
which means i'll never get the credit
for being a genius if this works
but also it like it's kind of like the
parent dies so the child can survive
it's like the only way a currency like
this could have really worked is if you
couldn't point to the creator because
then they would just attack the creator
they would say the creator has too much
they'd say this guy has a ulterior
motives he has control he's he's too
powerful to you know he's just the new
the new bad guy you know okay you're bad
at the federal reserve and the
governments uh yeah now you're mad at
this guy for for private citizen being
in control of this so do you think this
is him
i personally think it's him um like i've
looked into a couple times about like
who are the most likely candidates um
you know is it a group of people uh was
it the government themselves was it one
person and it does seem like it was
like you know i guess like i shouldn't
say it does seem like it there's really
no evidence
of the existing evidence that's there
this kind of like speculative data point
you have how phineas fits the story in
my worldview the best so i think it's
him god that's i love these mysteries
which would mean that it's it's sort of
gone like his coins are locked up um
unless he gave him to his wife unless he
gave her the keys uh and like you know
and she and told her don't touch it
because it hasn't moved no not a single
coin has moved uh ever and um you know i
think if he did it let's say he did give
her instructions how would i give
instructions i would say
um i would probably not actually let her
have it i would say
this file is going to be available to
you on this date
um 20 years from now
and i would say you know follow the
instructions inside so i wouldn't even
give her the opportunity to make a bad
decision
because i would say if these move before
bitcoin wins
um then it'll be this will be just very
destructive for it like if the creator
of bitcoin starts to sell bitcoin that
will trigger like a huge sell-off in the
market because it'll be like oh the
creator's alive they don't believe
they're selling their coins who is it
it'll create this like whole drama it'll
hurt the project but has any money ever
left his account no
not a single satoshi has ever left his
account so then he would have had to
have create a different account for her
to live on or something yeah which could
have easily happened right um
you know at some point but you know
people can also see the ledger so they
know who all satoshi sent the they know
which wallet satoshi sent coins to
and um some of them are like known
identities like the other people that
were in this like crypto like the
cypherpunk community that wanted to test
out the project early on
but like you know he very easily could
have just had her set up mining a mining
rig so it didn't even have to come from
his account he could just say because he
didn't give himself the coins he mined
the coins sure it's just that mining was
so easy at that time so
you know she could be minor number eight
um you know that mine some coins and
that's it that's she can live off that
yeah god well we should see like you
know house finney how's she living is
she like in a in a 40 million dollar
home in venice i don't even know if he i
i mean there's a woman with all these
pictures with him like it looks like a
wife i don't even know anything about
her i just
googled it it doesn't say anything about
wikipedia about his wife um
but oh yeah his wife yeah so he does
have a wife
yeah i'd be curious i'm looking at
pictures of his house when he's dying
like pictures of him dying and he's in
his home it does not look fancy
yeah
yeah also als just looks so brutal man
yeah it feels like the worst completely
debilitated
uh that's really tough yeah so anyway
that's fascinating we should do like an
entire episode on that that's this
is so interesting to me
yeah i agree we should we should just do
the research of like okay what is all
the research that's out there and like
what's the conclusion i think people are
i'm fascinated by like this story i
think it's one of the coolest
out of straight out of a movie but it's
actually real life things that has ever
happened you know i like that and silk
road but i think the silk road case is
far more cut and dry than anyone thinks
i think ross did it i think ross did
everything
right